comment sortir de cette crise politique
consécutive à l'activation par le
gouvernement de l'article 49-3 pour
faire passer en force au Parlement la
réforme des retraites on en parle avec
notre invité Jean-Noël Barrault bonjour
à vous et bienvenue à vous sur Sud Radio
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et déter le communication dans
du parler avec vous de régulation du
porno sur le net on aurait dû parler
avec vous de la fibre pour tous les
Français mais voilà la place de la
Concorde était légèrement enflammée hier
des manifestants des manifestations
éclatent un peu partout en France on
était il y a une demi-heure un peu plus
d'une demi-heure en direct d'une
raffinerie dans le sud-est du pays et
l'un de nos invités Sébastien veragnols
représentant CGT justement avait un
message à vous faire passer pour retirer
la réforme aujourd'hui on n'est pas
c'est pas une question de guerre de clan
c'est pas une question d'ego non plus je
crois que cette réforme elle a pas été
ni comprise ni validé ni acceptée et la
majorité du peuple aujourd'hui la veut
pas donc on lui demande juste de nous
écouter en fait c'est tout alors ce
qu'on pourrait rapprocher de
l'intervention de notre auditeur à
l'instant au 0826 300-300 Manu qui
disait on ne sent pas de bienveillance
dans ce gouvernement ce gouvernement
vous en êtes qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez
que si on a voulu faire cette réforme ce
n'est pas pour le plaisir mais c'est
parce que elle était indispensable elle
est indispensable parce que comme la
note du haut-commissaire au plan la
rappeler chaque année nous nous
endettons de 30 milliards d'euros pour
tenir à l'équilibre notre système de
retraite il y a il y a aucune famille de
France ou durablement on irait
s'endetter sur le compte de nos enfants
et donc il nous faut remettre de
l'équilibre dans ce système de retraite
par répartition c'est la responsabilité
que nous avons vis-à-vis de nos enfants
et c'est ce que nous devons leur laisser
un pays une France un système social
dans lequel ils auront le choix et
surtout dans lequel ils pourront
bénéficier de cette protection coffre le
système de retraite par répartition la
protection de ce qui est le patrimoine
de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas ce que vous
le dites vous ne l'avez pas fait pour le
plaisir ça ne fait pas plaisir à
l'opinion publique ça soit dans les
sondages très majoritairement opposés à
cette réforme même 40% de l'électorat de
la MA trouve l'usage de l'article 49-3
excessif ou que c'est en tout cas une
mauvaise nouvelle ça fait énormément de
mécontents tout ça pour ça il faut
rappeler que ce texte est très forme des
retraites elle a fait l'objet de très
nombreuses heures de discussions à la
fois avec les syndicats et au Parlement
il faut rappeler que mercredi les 7
sénateurs et cette députés représentant
les composantes du Sénat et de
l'assemblée se sont mis d'accord article
par article sur ce texte sauf qu'il n'y
avait pas de majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale pour voter ce texte sinon vous
n'auriez pas utilisé
l'article 49 3 il y a pas de majorité
pour la faire passer cette réforme le
texte une pour faire tenir le
gouvernement le texte a été voté au
Sénat et à l'Assemblée nationale les les
LR notamment qui dans la commission mix
paritaire où ils étaient représentés à
hauteur de 4 membres avec voté cette
réforme et bien l'Assemblée nationale il
n'était plus tout à fait certain qu'il
le ferait comme nous considérons que
cette réforme est indispensable pour nos
enfants alors c'est tout le gouvernement
vous l'avez dit qui a engagé sa
responsabilité sur ce texte sauf que sa
responsabilité engagée par l'article
49-3 ça a été vécu comme une gifle par
une bonne partie des opposants à la
réforme des traits on le disait des
flammes en tout cas un bûcher symbolique
allumé hier sur la place de la Concorde
qui porte décidément bien mal son nom
depuis quelques mois on a eu des
interpellations aussi du côté de Lyon le
climat est absolument irrespirable et
beaucoup de gens beaucoup de gens
craignent que ça ça dégénère
je déplore les violences qu'on a qu'on a
pu voir hier soir je constate que nous
avons eu de grandes manifestations tout
au long de la discussion autour de ce
texte des retraites qui se sont passées
dans le dans le calme grâce notamment à
l'action des forces de l'ordre auquel je
veux rendre hommage ce matin donc il n'y
a pas la place pour la violence il faut
respecter la démocratie parlementaire
lundi
la responsabilité du gouvernement sera
engagé autrement dit un vote aura lieu
qui conditionne l'avenir du gouvernement
respectons la démocratie parlementaire
laissant le vote se faire mais regardons
quand même la manière dont cette réforme
passera peut-être si et seulement si les
deux motions de censure sont rejetées
par l'Assemblée nationale votre bloqué
au Sénat délai limité pour examiner
cette réforme des retraites à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat et à la fin
article 49 3 on a l'impression que le
gouvernement a été contraint d'utiliser
tous les artifices constitutionnels pour
faire passer cette réforme en force de
manière peut-être légale
mais en force je le répète le texte sur
lequel sur la base duquel le
gouvernement gage sa responsabilité est
un texte qui a été revu article par
arctique par cette sénateur cette
députés représentant toutes les nuances
du Parlement je suis un démocrate je
suis très attaché à la démocratie
parlementaire le gouvernement agé a
engagé sa responsabilité c'est un vote
lundi qui déterminera si oui ou non
cette réforme doit se suit son cours
vous êtes aussi un centriste
historiquement
se sent triste aussi qui pose cette
motion de censure et qui l'assine c'est
Charles de cours sont c'est incentriste
historique qui n'est ni d'extrême gauche
ni d'extrême droite ne l'a jamais été
pourtant il fait d'air autour de lui les
opposants à cette réforme d'autres
députés de votre partie le modem comme
Richard rameau savait manifesté
seulement qu'on puisse dire leur manque
d'emprunt à la voté cette réforme
pourquoi même chez vous ça a coincé
Charles de Courson il est à l'Assemblée
nationale il n'est pas dans la majorité
présidentielle au Sénat comme à
l'Assemblée quasi uneanimité de celles
et ceux qui se revendiquent du centre et
du courant démocrate ont exprimé qu’il
était de leur responsabilité de soutenir
cette réforme c'est une responsabilité
que nous avons vis-à-vis de nos enfants
je le répète l'objectif c'est de pouvoir
transmettre à la génération qui vient
après nous le système de retraite de
répartition dont nous avons hérité de la
génération qui est venue avant nous
alors un mot aussi pour rappeler que
vous êtes élu dans les Yvelines mais
vous êtes un enfant de la Haute-Loire je
reviens quand même à cette tension parce
qu'une image qui nous avait profondément
marqué pendant le mouvement des gilets
jaunes c'était l'incendie de cette
préfecture c'était au Puy-en-Velay
est-ce que vous craignez pas que ce
genre d'épisodes se répète cette nuit la
mairie du 4e arrondissement de la ville
de Lyon était saccagé par des
manifestants
je déplore et je dénonce toutes les
toutes formes de violences je regrette
que certains y compris au Parlement émis
de l'huile sur le feu moi qui suis un
démocrate et qui est grandit en
Haute-Loire ce que je souhaite c'est que
tous les débats que nous avons aussi vif
aussi vigoureux qu'il soit puisse tenir
à l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée nationale et
au Sénat ceci étant dit il y a cette
incontestable une forme d'attente dans
le pays qui ne concerne pas seulement la
réforme des retraites mais mais d'autres
sujets sur lequel sur lesquels la
majorité préventive autour du président
de la République est pleinement mobilise
et je pense à l'école je pense à la
santé et je crois beaucoup pour ma part
ce qui a initié le président de la
République qui est le Conseil national
de la refondation et j'invite toutes
celles et ceux qui qui nous écoutent et
qui qui qui ont des des motifs
d'insatisfaction sur ces sujets à
participer à toutes ces discussions à
toutes ces concertations un lieu au plus
près de chez eux sur l'école sur la
santé sur le pouvoir d'achat pour faire
avancer ensemble notre pays à la
concertation après avoir activé lactique
le 49 3 vous en êtes conscient en un mot
quand même en elle barreau le Conseil
national de la refondation il a pas été
décrété aujourd'hui ça fait 6 mois que
dans toutes les écoles de France dans un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux ces
discussions ont lieu pour essayer de
construire ensemble et à partir des
ressentis du terrain les solutions dont
nous avons besoin pour demain deux
aspects qu'on aurait dû aborder beaucoup
plus en longueur mais qui vous concerne
directement aussi en tant que ministre
d'élégué en charge du numérique l'accès
à tous les Français c'était une promesse
de tous les Français à la fibre d'ici
2025 pour se faire les opérateurs
téléphoniques demandent un deal
équitable au gouvernement ce serait quoi
se dit l'équitable nous avons en dix ans
atteint des objectifs qu'on s'était
fixés ce qui est pas toujours le cas en
France c'est-à-dire de faire en sorte
que 80% des des bâtiments des locaux
dans notre pays soient raccordables
désormais nous avons un objectif qui est
explique en 2025 les Français et tous
accès au très haut débit et que la fibre
soit généralisée cela ça suppose qu'on
puisse offrir aux Français des
conditions d'accès au trait au débit à
la fibre qui soit accessible qui soit
fiable et qui soit abordable et cela
suppose de la part des opérateurs de la
part de l'État et sans doute de la part
des collectivités un effort conjoint
nous sommes en train d'en discuter avec
eux pour que allaiter nous puissions
présenter aux Français les bannière dont
nous allons leur offrir cet accès
généralisé votre débit et vous êtes
aussi en charge de la régulation des
réseaux sociaux un internaute célèbre
internaute célèbre et revenu cette nuit
il a dit i'm back sur un ton triomphal
c'était sur Facebook et sur Youtube
c'est Donald Trump qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez bienvenue ou welcome back
ou alors attention à ce que vous publiez
ce que je lui répond c'est que depuis
qu'il est parti les choses ont changé et
que en Europe nous avons mis en place
sous l'impulsion d'ailleurs de la France
et d'Emmanuel Macron un cadre de respons
abilité pour les plateformes qui ont
désormais une vigilance à avoir sur les
contenus et notamment la diffusion de
fausses nouvelles le la diffusion du
cyber-harcèlement sur sur leur
plateforme c'est un c'est un règlement
qui va entrer en vigueur dans les dans
les prochains mois dans tous les États
membres de l'Union européenne et sur
lequel nous aurons à prendre un projet
de loi dans les prochaines semaines donc
non pas attention à Donald Trump mais
attention à Facebook et Youtube c'est de
la se passer des dérapages merci
Jean-Noël Barraud d'être intervenu sur
Sud Radio ministre délégué chargé de la
transition